بشكر انا اللجنه عملت لنا هذا المشروع
ووفرت لنا هيك مكان داف لي وللطفل لان انا
بعيني من الولاده القيصريه كثير يعني سواء
من الحمامات ومن ال قصه الدفا من العلاجات
كثير مهمه ل الطفل زي هذا لان هو اصلا في
هذا العمر ما بياخذ علاجات يعني لا سمح
الله اذاعيه في له اي علاج يعني هذا
اذاعيه فش يعني على التبخير او بده يضله
زي هيك احنا من انا ولما ولدت ابني الوجع
صار معتي هبت على صدره ما قدرتش اني احميه
يعني من البرد يعني برد كثير حتى فيش
اواعي موفره له يعني ايش الاواعي اللي
لابسها خفيفه كثير فاضطر ننام فيه في
المستشفى وحتى المستشفى فيها رعايه هذا
المشروع كثير منيح هنا هيوفر له تدفئه وفي
حرامات منيحه وفي ثياب في كل شيء له موفر
الحمد لله اما طفل لعمر 15 يوم حرام ين
وجع الوجعه هذه اللي ان وجعها ان الاطفال
اذا تم وجودهم في البرد القارس في هذه
المخيمات يؤثر على صحتهم ويدخل في مضاعفات
تؤثر على حياتهم وتهدد حياتهم بالخطر ونحن
كنازحين
نناشد جميع الدول العربيه بتوفير الرعايه
الكامله والصحيه لاطفالنا وامهاتنا
لحمايتهم من اي كارثه ومن خطر الموت هذا
المخيم تقريبا يحتوي على 6000 نازح
فبالتالي هذه الفكره يعني قد يكون مثيل
لها في المستشفيات تسمى نيرسري روم او
غرفه الحضانه للاطفال لكن في ظل هذا
العدوان وفي ظل هذا اللجوء ان يكون بهذه
الامكانيات المتواضعه فكره ابداعيه كهذه
الفكره مع مقومات قد تعين الام لفتره من
الزمن على ان تقوم بالعنايه بطفلها فتعتبر
هذه من الافكار الابداعيه وهذا ما عودنا
عليه ابناء شعبنا الابداع حتى في ظل اقصى
الظروف
ه